- Hello mindless cogs,
and welcome to the 7 Million
Habits of Highly Effective
Hampton Deville Employees.
- Habit number 428,
remember everyone's name.
- Remembering the names of
coworkers makes you seem
invested in and
focused on the company.
- And if you have a hard time
remembering people's names,
try this handy little trick.
- Associate names with memories
that mean something to you.
- For instance, I associate
John's name with a memory
of an earthquake that
destroyed my childhood home.
- And I associate Kate's
name with a memory
of the affair I had with the
admissions director at Yale.
- Nice.
- His name was Glen.
Worse case scenario, if you
can't remember someone's name,
you can always just be like,
Hey, hey you.
- Oh hi.
- How's it going?
- Hey good.
- How are your adorable little?
- Parents?
- Your parents, how are your
adorable little parents?
- They're fantastic.
- Yeah?
Oh by the way my name is John.
(screams)
And that's how you do it.